(cheerful upbeat music)
All season long, we're celebrating towns and cities
across the country, as many as we can.
We're bursting with hometown spirit.
Eli Schmidt and Will Grimes's hometown
of Denver, Colorado is next.
They even host a YouTube show about it.
Show us around Denver, you guys!
Hey, Drew, I'm Will Grimes.
This is my business partner, Eli Schmidt.
We are the Mile High Property Brothers.
Today, we're at CBS4.
We're gonna be showing you everything we love about Denver,
more importantly, what you might not know about Denver.
But it's work hard, play hard here.
What do you love, Eli?
Guys, people in Denver, we love to work hard,
we love to get after our business,
but even more so, we love to have fun.
We freakin' love it here.
So we're gonna check out what a typical day
for a Coloradan might look like.
(light upbeat music)
Here we are at Washington Park, in the heart of Denver.
This park, guys, is centered around one
of the biggest focuses that locals have in Denver,
and that's fitness.
There is no lack of things to do here.
(up-tempo bass music)
The Dairy Block is often not known from even the locals,
so it is a true secret spot.
It is what they call an activated alley, or micro district.
They've actually taken what was a normal alley,
just between two big buildings,
and they put restaurants and shops,
some interactive artwork.
On the weekends, you can find farmers' markets,
you can find bingo, karaoke,
all sorts of cool stuff out here.
(cheerful upbeat music)
We could not let you guys go
without showing you an actual speakeasy.
Typically, we don't tell you the name,
we don't tell you where we're at,
you just got to figure that out.
But today, where are we at, Eli?
That's right, taking us all the way back
to Prohibition era, which was huge in Denver.
We are at Williams & Graham,
the speakeasy that is nestled
behind a super secret bookstore.
Come on in, guys.
I'll meet you by the curtain.
We are inside with the owner right now.
Man, while you're fixing these drinks,
can you tell us a little bit about your business?
Wanted just the history behind it.
Sure, we've been open now for 10 years this year.
In 2015, we were named the top 50 bars in the world.
Very cool.
Awesome.
(glasses clink)
What a pleasure to show you guys
everything Denver means to us.
Guys, Denver's fit, it's active,
we're progressive, we're about our business,
but we're about our food and our fun as well.
So if you're thinking about coming out this way,
or at least paying us a visit,
make sure you reach out.
See you guys next time.
Wow, Denver looks so amazing,
and I know you guys have incredible museums.
I can't wait to visit!
Will you show me around too?
(lively music)
♪ Oh-oh, oh ♪